it's been a pretty emotional season so
far for Betty I'm assuming the journey
isn't over yet what's still to come for
Betty and success honestly it's so
exciting for me knowing what's coming
and knowing what the fans are in for and
they have literally no idea what's about
to hit them especially in the coming
episodes I mean it's kind of like you
think maybe Betty's done being tortured
and then you're like oh nope
joke's on you she goes through so much
this season I'm not sure how she's still
hanging in there but she is she's a
tough cookie but I mean she goes through
these unbelievable circumstances and
she's lucky enough that she has Archie
and Jughead and Veronica around her to
help her navigate through that and even
her mom I think Betty and Alice's
relationship in season two is I really
love it not because I love well because
I love machen so much and working with
her but also because I just think their
relationship gets stronger and and I
guess you kind of learn to sympathize
with Alice a little bit more than you
did in season one there's been a lot of
talk about dark betting lots lots of
talk about dark Betty I don't know if
that's the official term but that seems
yeah well we we see the return of dark
Betty in season two yeah yeah you see
lots of different shades of dark Betty I
feel like you know you say dark Betty
and you think of the black wig and the
lingerie and the heels and drowning a
man in a hot tub but it's a lot it's not
just black and white you know there's a
lot of a lot of shades to her and just a
lot of depth to Betty in general so her
darkness comes out in a lot of different
ways and you see it
shown in very different ways throughout
the rest of the season but it's it's
coming would you say you prefer playing
Betty or done Betty I mean I love I love
Betty for who she is it's fun to play
dark Betty because I know how much fans
love to see it and but I mean I like
ogee Betty I mean this show has become
for lack of a better word like a
phenomenon this show is huge it's
incredible yeah when you read the script
for this the first time obviously you
want to be on a show that's successful
but did you have any idea no I mean I
remember reading the script I was like
sitting in my living room on the couch
watching TV flipping through on my iPad
and and I mean it I was it was
intriguing and I liked that there was a
darkness to it that wasn't you know like
every other show on the air teen show or
shows starring young adults so that
automatically drew me in but I mean
there was no telling what it was gonna
be and I wasn't really familiar with the
Archie comics at all so I didn't know
the universe that existed within
Riverdale and all of the fans that were
gonna come with it which you know we're
fortunate enough to have had a built-in
fan base which I think has helped the
success of our show immensely but um no
I mean but I was on board right from the
pilot I loved it and with each script I
got I was hooked more and more and it's
it's amazing to be on a show that you
actually love and would watch I feel
like maybe not every actor is this
fortunate to have that but I definitely
am 100% and what I love about the show
is there's two things hey like I was
saying for your co-stars it could have
been very sticky sweet and kind of
boring and bland and vanilla yeah but
the show is went on the flip side it's
dark it's gritty you know and I just
think it deals with so many real topics
we're dealing with drugs we're dealing
with slut-shaming I know stuff like that
do you think dealing with those topics
that your viewers may be actually going
through and real
life helped with the success I mean
definitely and it's unfortunate to know
that you know the the hard and dramatic
and intense topics that we're talking
about on our show are things that people
actually dealing with you know like
sexual assault and and stuff along those
lines but it just I feel like it just
adds an element to our show that's a lot
more real and and it does show a
darkness that maybe people aren't used
to seeing you know you don't really see
too much of sexual assault happening to
young teenage girls in high school you
know and it's just kind of a reality
that um we show no what we shine the
light on